SUBJECT 1: Let me
start out by saying
this isn't an oil
painting, nor is
it a work of stained glass art.
This is a photograph of
rice fields in rural China
during what can only be one of
the most beautiful sunsets I've
ever seen.
This is definitely a
different side of China
than I'm used to seeing.
THIERRY BORNIER: Hi.
My name is Thierry Bornier.
I'm a French photographer--
specialist of China Iandscape.
I captured this image
in China Yunnan Province
in the country of Tuantang
in February, 19, 2014.
SUBJECT 1: You
may not have heard
of the remote Chinese
county of Tuantang,
but it's famous for
pictures like these.
Photographers flock to
this area to capture images
of these terraced rice fields.
Farmers builds steps into the
sides of mountains or hills
in order to take advantage of
the otherwise un-farmable land.
This system helps
catch rainwater
that helps keep the
nutrients in soil.
And the resulting
landscape is breathtaking.
THIERRY BORNIER: This
image is about a rice field
in Yuangyang, the
biggest one in China.
I was very lucky because
the mood of the sky perfect.
Harmony between
clouds and sunset.
To give the final mood
of "God's Palette."
SUBJECT 1: And China is
full of beautiful landscapes
like these.
Many times when
you hear of China,
it's about its major cities,
polluted and overcrowded.
But there is a wild China, full
of amazing, natural wonders
and stunning panoramas.
You can travel to see wild
pandas, tigers, monkeys,
and wolves.
Experience stunning mountains,
rivers, lakes, national parks,
and of course, rice fields.
THIERRY BORNIER: When I
take image about landscape,
I'm very concerned
about the future.
It's why I try to
capture them the most
authentic with the best
scenario of lighting
to be sure they will never
be forgotten from our memory.
We live in the world where
climate change and modernists
make them disappear
step by step.
It's a huge beautiful
country full of diversity.
And so exciting
because I can always
meet new people from
a different ethnic
and with different culture,
including dialect and food,
as example.
But when I arrive
in a magic place
I know I need to stay
there as long as I need.
I am so happy to
have found my passion
and to be free to do
what I want in my life.
SUBJECT 1: Want more
that's happened here?
Check out this episode on
these mysterious toxic pools
you can only see from a plane.
SUBJECT 2: These
uniquely colored pools
sitting in what looks like
the literal middle of nowhere
are no doubt strange, but
they're also somewhat familiar.
SUBJECT 1: And don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.